this is where it takes me to and i think
you're going to disagree but i want to
hear you
on why you're going to disagree with
this my opinion
when reagan came overnight romani gave
the prisoners of war you remember that
and
reagan gave the credit to carter when
they say hey you know they're releasing
the prison award and reagan could have
taken the credit because
romani knew reagan's going to do
something about it he didn't feel like
carter was going to do anything about it
he thought carter was just a nice
president nobody feared and reagan said
it's because of carter he give the
credit to him
as much as
80 million people voted against this guy
name i don't know if you've heard of his
name donald j trump right they voted
against this guy
and 76 whatever million people voted for
him
while he was president
we may have had a lot of riots we may
have had a lot of protests in the u.s we
may have had a lot of stuff that was
going on in the u.s
nobody even talked about isis for four
years
nobody talked about anything he put
china
held them accountable with all the
issues that was going on with the
sanctions and everybody else so there
was a certain level of fear to know that
no one was going to do anything uh under
him do you think a situation like this
gives the opposing side an argument to
say well this is exactly why they didn't
fear trump if trump was in a house right
now this would have never happened
that's why you hear millions of people
talking about right now i'm curious to
know what your thoughts are on this
well when we speak about afghanistan i i
believe that the biden and the trump
administration almost had the similar
objectives and when i say similar
objectives both of them
wanted no boots on ground both of them
wanted a similar exit strategy and both
of them did not want any kind of an
interference from the united states
anymore in the internal situation in
afghanistan now many believe i've seen
those tweets i've seen
articles being written columns being
written and many experts arguing that if
trump was here perhaps this was not
going to be an exit strategy i
personally do not believe that i think
that the exit strategy could have been
would have been similar uh
you know there was no detailed planning
of even uh how the bagram air base
should have been kept in the last moment
and i think
whatever the military commanders down on
ground advised the biden administration
the same advice would have been gone uh
to the trump administration and similar
action would have been taken secondly
you know when it comes to china one has
to realize and study the pattern that
china has
really got into in the region uh their
dynamics to become a superpower and when
in 2012 2013 xi ji ping came to power
his entire project his speeches about
china dream his vision of china tree and
his tendency of expansionist tendency
his vision of china's expansion
across the region and the globe you know
we've faced this here in india where
uh just last year after 40 long years we
had a situation in ladakh the
northernmost part of india where
the chinese came in and there was a
confrontation and 20 indian soldiers
lost their lives uh they also had a
situation in the same confrontation many
of the chinese soldiers were killed some
figures say that they were 30 to 40
chinese soldiers but china never as it
always happens they've never came up
with a figure later a year later they
came out that six or seven of their
senior soldiers were killed in that
confrontation so the expansionist
tendency has been there time and again
another
important factor of economic upheaval
that china engages in is the dead trap
it has done that in sri lanka in
maldives in many uh places in uh african
african region in
somewhat places in the middle east also
djibouti and others
so this
death trap is something that
china is going to exploit in afghanistan
as well now how it does that with the
taliban is something that one needs to
see because taliban does not have any
kind of a recognition or diplomatic
recognition right now from any of the
global countries there are only a
handful that are willing to cooperate
and go along with them apart from of
course
the united nations humanitarian aid that
will come in but how will the dead trap
strategy really work in afghanistan i am
curious about that i'm really curious
about how china takes about the
important infrastructure projects in
afghanistan because you know it's it's
soviet union has been there has done
that the united states has been there
done that and they have seen the
failure
of their any kind of uh
a situation of nation building or any
kind of a governance with such ethnic
strife with such kind of a you know even
illiteracy uh out there so how will
china manage is something that one has
needs to witness because
it could be again uh patrick that a
decade from now you would be
interviewing me or i would be
interviewing you and we will be
discussing how china is now exiting uh
afghanistan so it would be a similar
situation but
uh you started your question comparing
the biden administration policies with
the trump administration or carter or
carter trump or carter like the
similarities between carter and biden
and then how trump would have had
military go last rather than military go
first because my challenge is purely a
sequencing challenge why did military
leave first you leave military at last
before you get everybody out the so
that's the biggest difference between
trump's existence the objective is the
same no one's saying first of all trump
never wanted to go in there anyways in
the first place 20 years ago he did a
whole article about the fact that you
know going against bush you know i don't
i don't force new york times or usa
today so he's never wanted to be there
but to leave leaving with soldiers last
rather than leaving with that's why i'm
asking about the sequencing side and
then comparing biden and carter as being
nice people
but does the world fear those two i
think history says no
well uh i agree with you but you know
i'll give you one example and this
is where i will
end this particular argument you know
what the united states did in
afghanistan over the last 20 years apart
from the military occupation that
happened
they let a corrupt regime prosper
they let
drug mafia and drug growth heroin
hashish ganja
and opium grow massively this is what
they did
there was a point and perhaps i don't
have the latest figures right now with
me but 93 to 95
of the global heroine and
opium came from afghanistan
i mean the kind of killings that are
happening all across the globe the drug
mafia killing the drug lords etc their
production their entire epicenter was in
afghanistan
and secondly
be it hamid karzai or beat ashraf ghani
ashwagani of course has become the
latest villain and a punching bag uh
perhaps for the united states
uh
they they were corrupt i mean everybody
knew this the u.s knew this the nds knew
it uh the regional governments here in
south asia knew it and still they let
them prosper i mean there was no
mechanism of transparency or some kind
of uh you know
questions being asked anywhere so
this led to a complete collapse as well
where you know you have a government
which only works for money which knows
that the us is going to arm you uh and
give you a lot of production protection
and give you money
and that's your end goal your end goal
is not peace your end goal is not
transparency your end goal is not to
keep your flock together and keep all
tribes and ethnic people together so i
think the united states failed in that
miserably as well where they could not
check one
the minutes of drugs
second the menace of a corrupt
government that only grew further and
third and the most important which i
emphasize
the menace of a nexus between the
pakistan isi the taliban and mushrooming
the terror group's sunni islamist terror
groups which are anyway now even
going to grow further so these are the
terrible mistakes that have happened of
course i completely agree with you that
the least
and the basic thing that perhaps even
any strategist from any of the top
universities in
us would have told them is that the
military needs to stay till the very end
you need to evacuate each and every
citizen first yeah by the way that's not
even democratic or republican that's not
that's not politics yes that's just
basic military strategy so
so who do you think ought to be and you
may or may not have an opinion on us who
ought to be held accountable in the
sequence of how we left who who is
supposed to be held accountable
for the way we left afghanistan
i think it is vital i mean
nobody else i mean trump uh
of course uh because the kind of
timelines that he set up were
unrealistic
i mean may first it was impossible to in
fact evacuate not just american citizens
other citizens from other countries or
afghan siv applicants and others who
anyway many of them are still stranded
there and the timelines were unrealistic
completely could not have been fulfilled
now biden says that there were timeline
set and he had to abide by it
is something that i do not agree with
what are negotiations for
what is your leverage for
why are you called a superpower over the
last many decades so i think they had a
certain amount of leverage they had a
huge amount of leverage in the
negotiations and they could have pushed
this further i agree and a strategy of
collapse that completely happened where
the military have would have advised
them because their focus was not
mind you patrick to evacuate people
their focus was to evacuate their
military so their strategy if you go to
biden statements in the past
if you go to statements of lincoln or
even other diplomats they say repeatedly
that these are the many troops that will
remain these are the many troops that
will remain and will exit finally so
their focus was not on these many
thousand innocents that will be
evacuated so
let's face it that now uh
lincoln might create a show all across
the globe that we rescued more than
hundred thousand people and uh that was
a major task
in the process 13 u.s soldiers also lost
their life but the reality of the matter
is that they never wanted to rescue
citizens that was not their priority
their priority was to exit this conflict
that was created by the united states a
monster that was created and perhaps a
monster that will remain for the afghan
people and perhaps the remaining few
afghan citizens so if you like this sort
of shortcut from an interview i did
click over here to watch the entire
interview and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye
[Music]